when a shark bites a human
they never get the same taste
let's say as they would by biting a fish
so generally they will release us and
swim away
these incidents were totally different
the shark came in
attacked the victim and came back and
attacked
again and again and again and
stayed with the victims until they were
removed from the water
that's a very determined animal so what
could cause sharks
to display such brazen determination
for collier there can be only one
explanation
in my opinion these animals were not
investigating
these were all predatory attacks these
sharks were attempting to feed on the
victim
sharks trying to feed on humans
it's a terrifying and virtually
unprecedented revelation
that's extremely unique and very very
rare
and we had to find out why so what could
cause
egypt sharks to suddenly start
attempting to actually eat
beachgoers
for dr dan huber such unnatural behavior
suggests that
something equally unnatural must be
occurring in the predator's environment
in fact it could point to some kind of
human
intervention animals can be trained to
exhibit certain behaviors in response to
a stimulus
and the reason why this works is because
the stimulus is associated
with a reward this concept is known
as conditioning one of the primary ways
that this happens
is if a shark gets hand fed over and
over and over again
it's learning to associate people with a
food reward
which means that it's going to exhibit
feeding behaviors around
people even if that food reward isn't
[Music]
present
[Music]
you